hamburg germany
december 1938
four years into adolf hitler's reign as
fuhrer
he is beginning to establish his total
dictatorship
by taking direct control of the german
military
but on the brink of world war ii hitler
is also involved in much stranger
endeavors that are hidden to the public
he is committing every remaining
resource to searching for ancient relics
that he believes could hold incredible
powers
they were looking all over the world and
that included antarctica
the full society actually believed that
there were mystics
or channels who were able to communicate
with these beings who claimed to be
either extraterrestrial in origin
or claim to belong to this civilization
that lived
in earth's interior they
gave a lot of information about the
building of advanced
aerospace vehicles flying sources and i
think this is where
hitler's nazi party got a lot of its
information about antarctica
that in antarctica there is this ancient
civilization
or bases where they could find a lot of
these advanced technologies
[Music]
hello plastic pills sterns hope you're
all doing well and surviving in the
midst of the apocalypse
but we're very excited today for a very
special episode uh where we have
not just professor but sir richard evans
uh with us today
to talk about his new book for the
hitler conspiracies professor evans for
those of you don't know
is the author of the third reich trilogy
uh which i went through over the
holidays
and i can say that it's not often you
see the word magisterial
um applied to books any longer but uh if
anything warrants the title certainly
the third right trilogy does
quite definitive so thanks a lot
professor evans it's really a
delight to have you here pleasure to be
with you
excellent uh so our first question is
just you wrote a three volume opus
uh on the third reich which covers
virtually every aspect
of its history military policy culture
you name it
uh what motivated you to return to the
subject matter for this new book the
hitler conspiracies
well i began to notice uh after the book
came out the third volume in 2008
that conspiracy theories which i'd
considered long since
uh debunked were beginning to come back
into uh into the mainstream so
uh i thought this is a an important and
and rather worrying development and
i got a grant to have a general
multi-disciplinary
look at conspiracy theories which we had
uh
seven post post doctoral fellows and i
had two co-collaborators and anything
from anthropologists to
um philosophers and so on uh internet
couple of internet engineers indeed as
well
so uh my part of that as well as overall
direction
was to look at these conspiracy theories
and i what i discovered is really quite
disturbing so
over the course of the grant i i wrote
uh a number of essays that then came in
became chapters
published them just last year just for
those uh readers who are not familiar
your book
opens with an introduction where you
talk about uh conspiracy theories
uh specifically you invoke uh the
paranoid style in american politics by
richard hofstadter as a major influence
but then you kind of focus on five
conspiracy theories in particular
uh so i was just wondering could you
talk a little bit about those five
conspiracy theories
and why you do specific attention to
them uh i should just say for personal
reference
the one that i thought was the most uh
informative uh was this
myth of the stab in the back uh which as
you point out in various things
motivated the rise of nazism
uh although the one that i thought was
the most i would say kooky uh was the
stuff about hitler uh being alive
uh and ufos well past 1945 and the ufos
and the arctic bases
you know our antarctica bases yeah well
of course and i started thinking about
conspiracy series
there are some that there are a couple
that are supposed to influence the nazis
uh in a very big way one of them was the
so-called protocols of the elder zion
which is a
an anti-semitic forgery uh which
historians uh have claimed
had an enormous influence on hitler
basically supplied him with what one of
them called the warrants for genocide
and inspired him to uh
launch and carry out the holocaust and
i looked began to look rather critically
at that one and
there's been a lot of new work on the
protocols in the last few years so
i incorporated that and that's the first
chapter and then the second one is about
what you call the snap in the back
that's the idea
as i should say the protocols of the
devil's design uh
it propagates the theory of a world
jewish conspiracy to
undermine western and especially german
civilization
and the second one was lab at the back
which uh was the
idea that had a lot of currency on the
german extreme right in the 1920s
after world war one that the german army
had not been defeated on the western
front in world war one
but it had been stabbed in the back by
the home
front or in another more narrow version
the socialists
uh on the home front and even more
extreme version the jews are the home
front
uh and uh so i looked at that and tried
to unravel it and look at its influence
that's been made responsible for example
for the fall of the
republic the democracy that ruled
germany between the war and
uh hitler's rise to power and there's a
different kind of conspiracy theory
which is a conspiracy theories
that i was a little bit more familiar
with before i started and that is
conspiracy theories about the nazi
germany and what went on
and one of them is the nazi deputy
leader rudolph hess
flew to scotland on the 10th of may 19
1941
uh with a peace offer and
it's the evidence is that that it was
his own idea he was trying to get back
some
uh of the power that he lost in the nazi
hierarchy
he thought by concluding a piece with
britain before just a few weeks before
the
nazi invasion of the soviet union
soviets poland russia belarus
and ukraine he uh he would
uh manage to stop a war on two fronts
not the nazi germany fighting against
the eastern against the west which he
thought had
proved so disastrous in world war one
and there are many conspiracy theorists
almost all of them in britain who
claimed that this was not his own
madcap idea but but the result of a
a plot concocted uh with hitler and
and others or a plot that was hatched by
the british to lure him over
and then i i also look at
conspiracy theories about the reichstag
fire now now this is
27 28 february 1933 hitler has
been appointed head of the german
government but it's a coalition
with conservatives he doesn't have
dictatorial power
and the german parliament building the
raj tag burned down
he claimed it was a communist plot to
stage a revolution
and managed to get an emergency decree
which essentially suspended civil
liberties and
it was uh really the first cornerstone
of his dictatorship
it's after that that uh there were
elections a few days
later in which the communists were being
arrested and weren't allowed to campaign
a really big party in nazi germany that
was the
the beginning of the nazi dictatorship
and again there are
uh there are conspiracy theories about
it the nazi's conspiracy theory was that
it was the communists who did it
and they put on trial a number of
leading communists
but the courts hadn't been completely
nazified at that stage
and they dismissed the charges for lack
of evidence
that left only one person who was tried
and
executed and eventually uh eventually
executed no
arson was not a crime at the time he
committed it
that was a young dutchman marina van der
lubbe
on the other side the communists
believed it was an artsy plot
and they staged a kind of mock
uh trial in london which found of course
found the nazis guilty
and that is the conspiracy theory with
legs that's the one that has been
revived consistently up until very
recently still believed in by many
people so i had a hard look at that
i should say that when i was uh 12 years
old that was like i actually believed
that in part because i watched a uh
a movie called uh the hitler the rise of
evil uh that heavily implied this right
so yes that was uh interesting there
were two tv programs part one and two
robert carlisles hitler
and the first one had my friend and
colleague ian kershaw the biographer
advising and it was very good but he
resigned because they wanted to
introduce too many fictional elements
into it and were taking up too much of
his time
and the second part is really terrible
and that's the one where they
propagate the idea of the reichstag
being burned down by
the nazis and there's a final one uh
which is hitler's
supposed escape from the bunker to go
and live in
argentina and that's the the final
chapter and then i wrap it all up by
talking more generally about conspiracy
theories and what i wanted to do is to
show
how by careful research
and investigation you can disprove
conspiracy theories and that is one way
one way forward i think in a world where
we're becoming
slowly overwhelmed by conspiracy
theories about
all kinds of different things i think
historians have to stand up
and be counted and say no this is bunk
yeah i was i was actually curious um if
you could comment more about
this kind of increase you said earlier
in conspiracy theories as a historian
sort of like what has your experience
been like seeing a change like how would
you describe the shift because i guess
some of the things you mentioned in the
book right
it does seem like there's more of a
cottage industry now of books being
published by people you know
on amazon self-publishing and then also
it seems like
the history channel really at the
beginning and it's at its origin you
know it really seemed like it was making
a serious attempt to do history
programming and now it's pretty much
always conspiracy theories so
if you could comment on that yeah i mean
of course they've always been conspiracy
theories and they've always been
conspiracies um
and you find on all the subjects that i
uh
cover in the book you can see conspiracy
theories in the 1950s 60s 70s and 90s
um for example uh the um
uh the escape alleged escape of hitler
from the bunker you find that being
propagated by
uh by stalin the soviet leader dictator
already just after after the war and
it's occasionally revived
but like the other subjects i deal with
it's become much more common
and much more widespread and that i
think
is largely mainly the influence of the
internet and social media
well actually i i had a follow-up
question then um just related to that
which is uh you mentioned you know
earlier in this interview that there are
two kinds of conspiracy theories that
you address in the book
uh one is conspiracy theories that were
either believed in or propagated by the
nazis
uh and the other conspiracy theories
propagated about the nazis
um the hess um incident and then hitler
surviving are the two main ones
so i'm just wondering if we could start
by looking at the first a little bit uh
and can you explain the appeal
of conspiratorial thinking let's just
call it that for right now
uh to uh the nsdap uh
why did it have traction in the party uh
you know what kind of conspiracies were
they prone to believing and what kind of
ideological function did they serve
well what i found was really i think
interesting is that
the nazis were not great conspiracy
theorists
if you look at stalin he sees a
conspiracy
on every corner and in fact in the 30s
he staged these purges and show trials
and
uh and executed a large number most of
his
uh his lieutenants um
and and many others and that's partly
because
he came into politics in a period that
was full of real conspiracies whether
you never knew who to trust
before world war one the treasurer of
the bolshevik party malinowski was
actually a czarist police spy
for example um and so he
uh didn't trust anybody and he'd come up
through the ranks as it were so when
lenin the founder of the soviet union
uh died stalin was not
his obvious successor and he had to
fight his way and maneuver and intrigue
his way through
all of these other prominent bolsheviks
prominent communists in order to get the
supreme position
uh hitler so he said he was very
suspicious of them and he
suspected them of plotting against him
and arrested them and forced them to
make confessions and had them killed
um now with uh and everything that went
wrong in soviet russia collectivization
industrialization there were always
things going wrong in these processes
and he chose to
blame them going wrong their failures
and problems on conspiracies
invented imaginary conspiracies but uh
that meant he let himself as it were off
the
off the hook now hillary's very
different hitler emerges
in the 1920s and almost straight away as
soon he becomes active in politics
is a leader he's the leader he's the
leading figure there's never any
question
that his lieutenants like goering
goebbels
hess and the others uh were second
ranked they owed their positions to him
their own allegiance to him
and so he wasn't he didn't suspect them
in fact the
light of rudolf hess uh came as uh to
scotland came as a terrible shock to him
uh as a lot of eyewitnesses who saw him
getting the news
uh i've have said um
so he's not nearly as much a a
conspiracy theorist
and now if you look in in that context
at the conspiracies which were kind of
uh around the theories that were around
at the time of the nazis um what i found
with the protocols of the elders of zion
was that in fact it didn't have nearly
as much influence
as many historians have said
this was a a document that was a
uh purported to be the minutes of a
meeting of jewish elders in 1897
plotting when you take over the world uh
it's a very peculiar document
and it comes from russia it's translated
into other languages
and it's uh propagated in english by
henry ford the
motor manufacturer who is a a deeply
anti-semitic
person and the protocols of the elders
of zion
were um the recording
the protocols that are designed reported
in the minutes of a meeting of jews in
1897 of elders leaders
uh who were passing all sorts of
terrible things
um it looked um
if you look at the actual miniatures
it's a very short
book they're very strange they're not
traditional
christian anti-semitism there's no
mention of the so-called blood libel
you mentioned that uh jews were
kidnapping
christian boys to use their blood for
ritual purposes
or the desecration of the host in the
communion
service in the eucharist or poisoning
wells or any of these things
there's no modern anti-semitism either
it's not a racist document
uh the jews are definitely treated as a
religious community in it
and there's nothing about sort of jewish
racial characteristics
trying to refute the ideas that you find
without you see might after you get the
emergence of racist anti-semitism in the
late 19th century so it's very much on
its of its own kind
um what it needed for people to
understand it was
to have commentaries on it and
subheadings and notes
and they're the ones trying to relate it
to modern politics in the 1920s and 30s
uh that i think have the influence but
most of all i probably don't
think people read it very much it's
quite difficult to follow and understand
certainly not a dangerous
rabble-rousing piece of of rhetoric what
they did was simply use it
as so-called evidence uh from the jewish
community itself
that they were plotting to take over the
world the idea that the jews are taking
over the world
or ran uh around the world or wanted a
revolutions and so on
that's around long before the protocols
it goes right back to the time of the
french revolution the late 18th
century now the crucial uh and you find
that that um
goebbels uh joseph goebbels who's
hitler's propaganda chief
actually didn't make use of it his staff
were always saying you can't use this
nonsense it's
just you know it's so ridiculous uh and
hitler doesn't mention it very much
uh and in fact he mentions it after he's
given his first anti-semitic speech in
his first enemy writings
uh so it's not it it doesn't influence
him in the past
uh it doesn't mention anywhere uh the
idea of extermination
of mass murder it's not a warrant for
for genocide uh i think norman cohen
although he was a very
brilliant writer the first book about
the serious book about the protocols
um was called warrant for genocide and i
don't think that's really
justified but there are a lot more
interesting things about the document
it's a um it's a forgery it's a tissue
of falsification
it was exposed after the end of world
war one when it came to currency
by a reporter for the london times in
istanbul
and uh he showed that it was a
cobbles together from a french satire
against napoleon iii in the mid 19th
century
and a passage from a german gothic novel
and bits and pieces put into it by the
russian compiler
who was probably parabel crochet van who
had
instigated a program involving in best
arabia involving the murder of 45 jews
and he cobbled it together to try and
justify that
that seems the most likely uh answer to
who
compose it though we can't really be be
sure
um and so it was a blatant forgery and
that was
uh it didn't come from the jewish
community at all
uh it was a falsification
and it not a very good one either and
that was all confirmed at a trial held
in bannon switzerland in the mid-1930s
now
if you look at what goebbels said about
it they said
it doesn't really matter if it's true if
it really is
the minutes of its meeting of of jewish
elders
or not what matters is that it reveals
they thought a deeper truth
about the jews and that is that their
racial characteristics
it's a pure racism here incline them
wherever they are
even unconsciously hitler says in my
camp
to be subversive to plot against western
civilization to try and overthrow
germany
and so on uh so the actual evidence
doesn't really
matter they felt they knew in quote
marks
that jews were were subversive and
that's a kind of pure racism
it's not it's a particular kind of
conspiracy theory because it
it's not that there's a group of jewish
elders sitting in a room
plotting everything uh that's that
doesn't work
it of course uh what
it does mean is for them for hitler
the nazis that this is imbued in the
jewish character
uh of course complete nonsense
uh but that is what that belief that the
jewish character was subversive
trying to destroy germany seemed to be
confirmed
by the uh protocols
fake or not and that is what led to the
holocaust
i actually i had a follow-up question
about this uh and then i know victor you
had a few things that you wanted to ask
um
i just wanted to say for our listeners
uh some of you might remember that i'm a
a critic of trump uh and reading this
section of your book where you talk
about how again hitler and doubles
decide
it doesn't really matter whether this is
literally true because it expresses a
kind of deeper spiritual truth
uh reminding me of some of the trumpets
who used to say that
we don't need to take trump literally we
just need to take him seriously
right uh there was this kind of
evocative quality to his rhetoric
that expressed something more important
than facts
but can you talk very briefly about the
kind of
way anti-semitism was structured in nazi
thinking
because one of the things that i've
always found challenging about these
doctrines and i understand that they're
vehemently racist doctrines and that
they're nonsensical
but was how the nazis simultaneously
used to hold that the jews were in
charge of
some kind of basketball or conspiracy
right uh to patrol germany and the
destinies of the west or
whatever it happens to be uh while at
the same time characterizing them as
sub-human
parasitic uh dirty uh because there
seems to be just such a blatant
contradiction here that
the mind wouldn't be able to hold to
these two things at the same time
uh and yet so many millions of people
did so could you maybe speak to that
briefly
yeah there were many contradictions in
nazi ideology and anti-semitism
and one of them was that the jews in the
nazi mind were simultaneously
parasites below the level of normal
human beings
but on the other hand uh they were also
uh incredibly dangerous and
very very powerful um
there's a very good jewish joke uh about
about this it's in the warsaw ghetto
during the the war and there are
two old men where friends and one of
them comes in and sees his friend there
sitting meaningly
reading the nazi newspaper in the tram
in the streetcar
and he says what are you what did moshe
what are you doing why are you reading
an arts in newspaper and his friend
looks up and says well
uh i'm living a terrible life it's you
can't uh
food i'm beaten by the nazis you know
it's really dreadful
so once in a while i buy the nazi
newspaper and i read there that
we jews are all powerful we are
incredibly influential we've done this
we've done that
um so that is a contradiction there's
another contradiction of course
uh but i mean let me deal with that one
first that is a contradiction because
you resolve it by saying well look at
i know locusts they can destroy whole
countries uh farmlands uh
you know look at look at uh ants they
can they can kind of tear down houses
and so on
so you can be simultaneously subhuman
and superhuman
uh again the other contradiction is most
obvious is that
uh in nazi ideology jews are said to
control all kinds of things banks
medical profession the law newspapers
all the rest of it
and they are said to be wealthy and
parasites upon the german people
but at the same time they're behind
communism and socialism
and so if you if you say well um well
hang on a minute you know
don't you think that communists and
socialists who are opposed to the big
banks and the elites
uh and the nazi answer to that
is that um not just jose cunningham
they're dividing the people
uh against themselves and that's a
characteristic of conspiracy theories
like that
is that they have an answer for
everything you cannot you cannot falsify
them
uh again if you say these these ideas
are ridiculously untrue
uh they will simply say well you must be
part of the conspiracy
yeah i remember one figure uh when
responding to accusations that the
protocols of
uh the elders of zion were falsified uh
i think it was hitler actually said
well this the fact that people are
making this accusation just goes to
prove how big the conspiracy
uh actually is right exactly exactly
yeah it's kind of like magic
well you mentioned hostdad and what
we're dealing here was a paranoid
paranoid style as he called it he's a
great
liberal writer of the 50s and 60s and um
the paranoid style is one that kind of
invents things
develops theories paranoid uh
theories and and fantasies in order to
account for
an uncomfortable reality right it's been
invented all so
none of the things have been talking
about has any bearing on reality
at all of course there were a few jews
who were among the socialists but the
majority were not
and they didn't have a disproportionate
uh influence on the socialist and
communist movements of course there were
some jewish bankers but the majority
were not jewish
uh and so on you look at these things
very carefully and these theories
crumble
so um yeah this actually segues nicely
into one one of the questions i had was
um
you know i think in the book you discuss
some of the common tactics that
conspiracy theorists tend to use like
they're kind of argumentative i think
for example in the last chapter
uh you bring up i think you're quoting
someone else talking about claim by
association
claim by implication uh arguments from
silence right and i wonder if you could
expand on
some of those tactics and how they work
argumentatively
yeah i mean it's interesting if you look
for example at conspiracy theorists
who are writing about rudolph hessen his
flight to scotland
with a bogus uh peace offer to
churchill which is entirely his own
invention
um and you say what about the evidence
and they will say well of course
you know the documents in the archives
have been taken out they've been weeded
out
in order to protect uh protect the
british political elite or whoever it is
uh if you look at the or people involved
like the duke of kent remember the royal
family who died
in a plane crash that must have been
deliberately caused in order to
silence him because he knew too much and
again you look at the
reichstag fire now what is interesting
about these two conspiracy theories
is that in both cases a single
person caused was was at the root of
root of events so um riddle house
there is no evidence that hitler sent
him hitler was shocked and surprised and
depressed there's no evidence
that anyone tried to lure him over it
was entirely his own idea there's a lot
of evidence
uh chronicling eyewitness accounts of
hitler being so shocked
nobody else is involved it was just even
the people who got the plane ready put
extra fuel tanks on it
uh and and helped it take off and so on
uh
they no idea that he was gonna fly all
the way to scotland
and of course it's crazy because the
duke of hamilton who he wanted to
see who was a leading figure and an
angry german friendship society but not
a pro-nazi in any way
uh was not the important political
figure hesitant completely
got it wrong it was another fantasy uh
but
people can't conspiracy theorists can't
believe
that has it was all his own idea and
when you look at can you say where's the
evidence you know well it's all being
suppressed you know the document's been
weeded out people like duke kent
have been killed and so on exactly the
same with the rice tank fire
which i mentioned earlier now the young
dutchman who was arrested and executed
marinus fonda lubber
he wasn't uh so he wasn't even a german
he wasn't even a member of the communist
party
and the nazis hang on him this blame for
a vast conspiracy
uh the i think if there had been a nazi
conspiracy
they certainly wouldn't have chosen
someone like van der lumber that had
chosen a proper german communist
uh the people who believe it was a nazis
started the fire again
you asked them where's the evidence uh
that it was a plot
and apart from sweep aside all the
speculation
and innuendo an invention
that's common to these conspiracy
theories uh you say well what about
there's any documents no the documents
have all been destroyed
uh or what about the eyewitnesses then
uh are then the people who are in on the
plot have all been killed they were
killed in the night over long knives
in 1934 um so you explain the lack of
documentation
as being a product of the conspiracy
that you're you're positing
and i found those similarities really
very very
uh striking and very telling i think
yeah it almost seems like they're using
the lack of evidence as evidence as
stronger evidence right as like a sign
that it's actually true almost exactly
these you know these conspiracies are
not really falsifiable in the normal
sense of the word
exactly and i also noticed you know one
you you made an observation about a lot
of this
sort of the cottage industry i know i
noted earlier of these
you know whatever uh conspiracy history
books that are showing up on amazon and
you know these history
channel documentaries where they they
use this tactic of uh speculation right
they say this might have been where
you know hitler escaped to this might
have been i wanted to talk about that a
little bit yeah
yeah there's a wonderful review of a tv
program
alleging that hitler escaped the bunker
in 1945 and went to live in argentina
uh that's i think it's a vanity fair
that says uh
you know if uh if you drank
a uh a whiskey every time
uh they mentioned uh he might have been
here
this might have happened this could have
happened you'd be completely
drunk by the end of the first ad break
you know
um so it's a lot of speculation joining
the darts
and and in a way that's not supported by
any evidence
yeah well this is actually where um i
thought it was very curious and i kind
of wanted to segue briefly to the
present uh
as we move closer to the end of the
interview because um the
last chapter as mentioned which concerns
uh whether hitler escaped the bunker
um you mentioned that there's kind of
not just a cod agenda industry but
almost an entertainment industry
that's kind of emerged around this
possibility and people have movies
hollywood productions uh some higher
budget some not
you know when hitler comes back and he's
a zombie or he's tortured or
i thought one that was really amusing is
uh you mentioned there's this movie it
was uh
i think produced by a german company
where the nazis established a base on a
moon
uh and then tried to reinvade earth
generations later
iron sky yeah there's not a fictional
there's a lot of movies you know the
boys in brazil
for example uh there's an an iron sky
is a truly terrible movie and it's
extremely entertaining i've very great
greatly enjoyed it it has i can
recommend it if you want to see every
single cliche about the nazis all down
all the way down to the blonde girl
dressed in an ss uniform and wearing
jack boots and so on
they're all there um oh i'm 100 gonna
watch it i thought it sounded hilarious
this is fun these are fun but nobody
takes them seriously
and what's different uh i think recently
including the 24-part series hunting
hitler is that this claim they claim to
be the truth
uh so people who believe that hitler
claimed that hitler escaped argentina
simply dismiss all the massive
investigations and research by
historians
by a a legal commission in bavaria that
sought to establish
hitler's death and an issue a death
certificate in the 1950s
um by houston rivaropa went into this
first uh
just after the war by many others
there's a lot of evidence the russians
the soviets
uh wrote a report with based on
interviews with
the two men who had buried
uh burned hitler and ever brown's bodies
in the garden above the right child
above the bunker um and others all the
eyewitnesses have been interviewed
all to tell the story the outlines are
very very clear
but these are dismissed by the
conspiracy theorists
as uh official knowledge so either they
were not telling the truth
and that's not the case at all no
evidence of that or they were kind of
why should they have been suborned into
saying hitler was dead when he wasn't
um there's no real reason behind it uh
interestingly afa brown who became
hitler's wife his long-term
companion was a professional
photographer and she took
um movies home movies photographs of
hitler
and his entourage mostly in
their mountain retreat in bavaria right
away up to the last
stage of the war um not a single
photograph has survived
after the war there's no evidence if
it's having been seen by anybody it's
all
second hand hearsay my mother had a
friend who says she saw hitler kind of
stuff
nothing is corroborated to see if when a
woman is produced
as having um uh irrefutable
direct evidence that he has survived she
was working
in a a house uh doing sort of cooking
and serving and so on
uh where a mysterious german visitor
appeared and she wasn't allowed to see
him
in argentina um she had to leave his
meals outside the door
and the chauffeur was at work for the
house whispered to her this is a hit for
that cigarette
uh so the meals she left were kind of
she said typical german food and she
never saw the guy
uh so the food that she made for him was
it finished stencils sausages all that
kind of stuff well
ella was a vegetarian he was a confirmed
vegetarian he would never have touched
sausages or
or venus so he had terrible terribly bad
teeth his
breath must have smelled dreadful and
but but he didn't touch it it's all
fantasy and she never saw him so that's
not confirmation is it not evidence at
all
so who's peddling this stuff well
there's a number of different motives uh
we all love a good conspiracy story i
mean of my favorite
movies you know i like the bourne movie
oh
i know i'd like you i'm a big fan too
they're great
well it's different matter when you
claim that this is the truth doesn't
really happen people are fascinated by
it
i think there's a strong dose of
admiration for hitler here
he was a man who started world war ii is
responsible for the holocaust he
uh was a a world historical genius even
if you think he was an evil genius
so he can't possibly be um uh
die they die this squalled death in a
hole in the ground and he shoots himself
in the temple
just before the red army uh arrives and
then the body is burnt and
and so on um he must have fooled the
allies somehow the what's interesting
thing about this the the evidence is
it's got non-existence
he's supposed to have uh flown out uh or
berlin
no evidence at all and highly unlikely
since berlin was a heap of rubble and
you couldn't land a plane there
uh at the end in late april um there
must have been a body double
uh he must have left earlier was
absolutely zero evidence
for that uh and it's particularly
suspicious because the man who's
put that theory forward also uh also
argued that rudolf hessen's body was not
rid of hass and
irish himmler the heavy heavy assess he
was not
his body was not himmler and so on um
so the evidence is entirely lacking the
submarines
supposed to have taken headless
argentina turns out to have been sunk
before the end of the war
uh one another submarine that's been
identified was carrying a cargo
cigarettes well he didn't smoke and
didn't allow
smoking in his presence and you go
through i go through all of these
theories there's admiration favor and i
think uh
some desire to make a bit of money uh
this is a profitable
enterprise showing films and publishing
books about hitler's
survival and people and people enjoy
reading them they
hunting hitler had three or four million
viewers
per episode so that's quite large and
that's even more important i think
to um present the evidence
and question what they're saying i was
wondering if um
i could ask you a question just as a
historian more broadly um because you
know matt and i are both
um political theorists effectively we
hang around with other philosopher types
and theory types and
i think one of the and i rarely uh find
myself reading uh history so you know
reading your book
i think one of the things that strikes
me and i'm reminded when i do go back to
history is
the way the the useful part of it is the
way you you will it reveals the human
tendency to repeat patterns of thinking
and behavior i suppose and uh
you know there's a couple examples that
jump out in your book i mean the one
that
comes to mind that i was like wow you
know is when
uh then you talk about how the nazis
work conflate the social democrats with
marxists right and it reminds me of the
way you know
republicans not to compare them to nazis
but you know that they
they will you know conflate obama with
socialism or something like that and
i wonder if you had thoughts or are
there any of those examples of kinds of
you know um repetition or human human
patterns of behavior that have stuck
in your mind over your years as being of
being a historian
yes i should say the social democrats
who were
the largest party before the nazis in
the by more
republicans democracy were marxists uh
they didn't jettison their marxist
marxism until well after world war ii
they were not colonists however and they
were and you have to remember the social
democrats and the communists
between them won more votes than the
nazis did in the last three elections of
the violent republic in november 32
but they were dagged on with each other
the social democrats were blamed by the
communists for the assassination of
their
leaders liebherr and luxembourg at the
end of world war one
um by right-wing troops actually
employed by
the social democrats who were in the
government at that time so um
what about these repetitions well i
think one thing that strikes me
immediately is if you look at
q and on uh okay this big conspiracy
theory
uh which has garnered a lot of support
particularly amongst trump supporters
you can see
quite a few people amongst those who
stormed
the capitol building on january 6th
wearing
cured on t-shirts or carrying kunan
banners this is a belief this is a
belief that
um even just talking about it seems
ridiculous but a belief that uh
donald trump is secretly leading a a
movement
to expose and destroy a worldwide
conspiracy particularly headed out by
democrats
hollywood actors george soros and others
to kidnap boys and
exploit them for sexual purposes or to
take um adrenaline from them
uh not them unconscious and and extract
adrenaline from them
now this is very similar to a medieval
a conspiracy belief that
the jews were taking a blood from
christian boys that i mentioned
earlier in our in our talk um i think
it's a
connected to that in some ways one
connection
might be the strengths of of extreme
evangelical christians
in the pro-trump movement but whatever
it is of course it's is
absolutely lacking in any evidence at
all it's just
the similarity between the two beliefs
are uh is really quite striking
yeah that actually reminds me i read an
article once that connected q anon and
also maybe traced back some of the
medieval history you're mentioning to
the satanic panic in the states of the
the 1990s right um where everyone was
afraid in the 80s and 90s of like you
know heavy metal music and there started
to be these rumors that
kids were being feasted on by uh these
satanists or whatever
yeah so they are similar i mean but what
what is interesting is that qnon
has a very large anti-semitic content
to it um and therefore you find these
kinds of beliefs are popping up in it
again
white supremacism is also uh of course
um also anti-semitic remember at the
charlottesville in 2017 in
in the uh um in the big extreme
right-wing demonstration there were
shouts of
uh jews will not replace us uh this this
another conspiracy theory in our own
time it's a great replacement theory
which
alleges that the white race as they'd
like to say
is being replaced by um other races
in in america and those include jews and
this is a
and you find these anti-semitic
conspiracy theories even
for example in the belief that the
rothschild banking company jewish
from the international jewish firm is um
sponsoring uh laser beams to come
from satellites going around the air
that started the california fires
and again that's connected to this kind
of conspiratorial interpretation of the
effects of global warming
right which again of course global
warming global heating skepticism is
a a serious and widely held belief on
the on the right in american politics
so uh one of the interesting characters
that appears near the end of your book
uh we point out you know we've deviated
uh some ways from the kind of hitler
survival myth here uh is jerome corsi
um who has deeper links uh in the
american kind of conspiratorial right
uh including to people like alex jones
uh who i should say was
my first encounter with some of these
conspiracy theories because uh one of my
roommates was doing his phd in film and
kind of had an interest in um
some of this uh interesting say uh
eccentric stuff that was emerging online
uh and you know jerome corsi uh you know
pushed forward
uh this idea certainly survived in
argentina
uh he also has 9 11 truther beliefs but
the way that he kind of frames all this
is quite interesting to me uh because he
positioned himself as kind of
anti-establishment figure
as you point out right that he was
challenging the official history
because what was actually happened was
being occluded from us
uh by this mysterious cabal of different
figures
uh and i did think that there was an
interesting and persistent theme
in your book uh this notion of the
conspiracy theorist is somehow
unraveling a truth uh that's been
deliberately concealed from us
uh and it has this kind of heroic
quality to it uh and i'm just wondering
if you could speak a little bit to that
and
do you think maybe that's one of the
reasons people find conspiracy theories
enticing
uh you know there's this notion of being
a heroic vanguardist figure who's
opposed to this kind of technocratic
bureaucratic
official history as it's sometimes
called yeah i mean as soon as you
see the phrase official history you know
you you've got a conspiracy theorist
there
um you know this idea that the entire
historical profession
uh journalists these players the media
they're all they're
all uh working for some unnamed
mysterious group of people whether it's
governor or not they don't have minds of
their own
now i find that's deeply insulting to
historians like myself
i make up my own mind about what what
happens and what's what goes on
and it's a dismissal of uh massive
amounts of detailed research
uh carried out by professionals over
many many decades
uh the conspiracy theorists said no this
is just a
rubbish so you find people who uh simply
i think without having read any of it uh
dismiss
the accounts of hitler's death in 1945
uh as official knowledge and say there's
no real
there's no real research or evidence
where it's in perhaps mountains of
it but because it's been done by
mainstream historians they dismiss it
and that's a kind of self-validation for
them you often find that conspiracy
theorists not always but you often find
that they are
um marginal in some way or they feel
cheated or they feel
uh shut out from the political process
or they feel
like losers uh and this is a way of
reassuring themselves that
we know better we know the real truth
you
the official knowledge avails you don't
uh i think that's very interesting on
the part of
trump supporters some of them who
won't accept that trump actually lost
the election
in november 2020 fair and square it must
have been a conspiracy
to default the american public jerome
corsi is an interesting character he's
oh sorry trump um
he wanted to lead back uh he hasn't it
he hasn't he's been involved in the
trump
movement uh and also with info wars and
with alex jones
uh he wants to lead back um
the obama regime and particularly the
affordable care act
to the nazis he wants to say this is a
nazi
plot and so he says that the american
state
or the deep state which is another
classic conspiratorial praise
the deep state um basically
took over a lot of nazi uh nazi uh ideas
and helped through the cia or the oss
its predecessor
helped hitler to escape and took on his
ideas and basically therefore
the uh affordable care act is nazi
it's a complete fantasy and totally
absurd but corty cause he has had some
influence
he began his political career with um
allegations against john kerry uh as a
presidential
stuff yeah yeah yeah which turned out to
be totally fabricated
yeah so my last question for you and
then uh victor i know you have a few
things that you wanted to say was uh
actually with regard to an article you
wrote in the new statement a statesman
uh this year uh where you argued against
some quite prominent uh public
intellectuals like jason stanley
and timothy snyder uh that trump is not
in fact a fascist
uh although as you point out uh con
insistently he's still very dangerous
and we'd
be better off seeing the back of him
right uh now i have my own kind of
uh stake in this uh since i wrote a book
about trump and i characterize him as a
postmodern conservative
and i'm sure plenty of our listeners are
tired of hearing about that so i won't
bore you with the details
uh but can you just kind of articulate
your argument for why trump
is not a fascist because i've
encountered many people who
aren't just insistent that he is but
they seem to feel that it's important to
label him as such i mean victor you you
talked about this yesterday right that
there's
a kind of visceral force in associating
him with this movement
then we can't deny yeah yeah the idea of
labeling somebody fascists of course
discredits them far more than anything
else in the view of people who call
trump the fascists uh just like calling
um i don't know calling a camera a camp
for
illegal immigrants um auschwitz or a
concentration camp i mean
you you use the most extreme rhetoric to
express your disapproval more strongly
but i think we
need to be a bit more careful about the
concepts we use and how we deploy them
so if you look back at hitler and
mussolini
you find that what was central to their
movements the italian fascism and of
course
the german nazism which borrowed a lot
from it is
war militarism uniforms
invasion and conquest of other countries
and when they achieved power the total
coordination and takeover of society and
the regimentation of society
and the militarization of society i
don't see any of that in in trump
um this is a trump's movement is a
chaotic movement based on uh i would say
walked and exaggerated ideas of the
freedom of the
individual is exactly lack of government
control that
uh that they want to impose he's been
withdrawing troops from other countries
it's isolationist in many
ways you can see the opposite of
genuine fascism in a lot of what trump
has done
what he is i think is an american
populist
in the style of american populism going
way back with many other
examples anti-democratic
dictatorial and
of course opposed to
neutral justice opposed to free media
all of these things but that doesn't
make him a fascist he's a populist
all fascists were populists but not all
populists are fascists and i think we
need to identify what he is where he
comes from and what he's doing
uh before uh in before we can actually
take take take action there's no use
fighting the battles of yesterday we're
not biting hitler or mussolini we're
fighting trump if that's the side that
you're
that you're on and i think you also have
to
situate them in this new era of mass
information mass disinformation overload
of information
uh the bypassing of the traditional
gatekeepers of opinion
uh fact checkers editors um
producers of uh newspapers radio tv
programs and so on the internet bypasses
all of them
and that is where we are at the moment
uh and i think we need to recognize that
and take steps
for me the most important thing
is to try and curb and stop
the flow of misinformation that is
coursing across the internet like sewage
and drowning us all absolutely
yeah i know for sure that resonates a
lot with me for a while i've been
arguing that uh
the fascist label you know it gives
people i kind of
lets people off the hook from actually
explaining what's bad about trump in
specific terms in a way
and there's a temptation i mean you know
not to conflate it with
uh conspiracy theories at all but i
guess i see like there's a there's a
human tendency to want simple
black and white answers and i think
maybe tendency to fascism is similar to
people's temptation towards
some conspiracy theories which i think
at one point in your book you talk about
as being black and white uh answers
that's right yeah so i did uh have
another question about about
back to the conspiracy theory um um from
the book
let me just see here um oh yes so at the
end of your book in the conclusion at
the beginning of the conclusion you make
a
a really interesting claim that i think
touches something really important about
the nature of conspiracy theories and
and you say that um
you know that in some ways they're a
result um in many ways of
i think you say a product of modern
science scholarship
appearing to share their most common
structure and modes of argument while at
the same time
radically challenging them and i thought
that that was really interesting and i
wonder if you could you could speak more
about that
well because it varies you know i mean
it's if you've got on the uh
on twitter you you can't really make any
serious arguments at all on twitter
articles uh which have been published
by conspiracy theorists about things
like
the assassination of jfk or 911 or
the ones that i deal with um you'll find
that they
are replete with all the kind of
apparatus
of modern scholarship they're overloaded
with footnotes
they're obsessed with tiny details which
they then blow up into
things that are much more uh important
than they
than they really are let me take one
example okay in the flight of rio hesse
um uh there are a lot of you know we
know
pretty well there there's the records of
once one sort of another by radar
stations
by the royal air force um and by and by
others
of the plane that he flew where it was
at any given time
uh on its way from germany across the
north sea to
scotland um western scotland uh so it
flew over a lot of
land as well now there's little
discrepancies in some of the timings
they tell a couple of minutes here a
couple of minutes there different
sources disagree
and this is blown up uh into by some
conspiracy theorists into an argument
whether
while the evidence is all falsified it's
all wrong but in fact
people didn't have electronic watches uh
they depended on
clockwork and uh on
often rather inaccurate timepieces so
it's not surprising there were
discrepancies
so that kind of detail and you find
pages and pages and pages of this
of this stuff so um i guess one other
question i had was
like maybe you touched on a little bit
but i was kind of just curious from for
my own
cure curiosity you know do you have a
favorite of the
outlandish hitler uh survival
conspiracies
that you ca that you come across in your
book yeah i love the one where he
uh is taken by a nazi flying saucer
uh equipped with anti-gravity uh to go
to a secret base underneath the
antarctic uh and
stay there sending out flying saucers
occasionally to see if it's safe to come
back into the world
that's my favorite exactly exactly and i
guess one last thing would be um
you've spoken to it you know the current
context of the internet being
like a real cesspool you know uh pushing
suit like
sewage of the sewage of conspiracy
theories you know i
i did wonder though there's also a
growing proliferation of debunking
conspiracy theories but but but on the
whole i guess you would say things are a
lot
a lot worse a lot worse of a situation
today than they've ever been you think
well you know people began the internet
and the world wide web with
incredible optimism this is going to
democratize knowledge
and so on uh and it has done that um
think of now uh it's just so much easier
to look up
accurate documented uh information than
it was like 30 years ago when you had to
go to libraries and archives and all the
rest of it
and uh it's there are a lot of fact
checking
websites out there if you think of
holocaust denial the the
denial extreme right winger's denial
that um
six million jews were killed and the gas
chambers are used and so on you can find
websites now
that present huge amounts of information
to disprove those
those uh that conspiracy theory uh you
know that's all been invented or
suppressed
um but at the same time there's a an
underbelly
of knowledge transmission
uh which is disinformation uh not to
mention of course the
huge amounts of violent
pornographic and uh hatred filled
and other kind of content that's come
over the internet
and that i don't think the people who
set the internet up really
really bargained for and that is i think
what
society has to grapple with uh i think a
beginning has
been made i do think that uh barring
trump permanently from twitter has been
the most serious flow he's
seen and depart from his not being
elected
uh in uh in the united states so
but i think it's a long way to go i
think there's a lot more things that
need to be done
yeah yeah and i think of websites like
snopes which has been around for a while
if you're familiar with it right debunks
i think conspiracy theories yeah it's a
good it's a good resource um
but in any case i was i guess maybe
lastly just off the top of my head
um are you working on any project any
new projects at this point
i i'm writing a book called hitler's
people uh
and researching it uh which is about uh
it's done through individual short
biographies explore trying to explore
why people supported hitler starting
with
his immediate entourage like gurren
goebbels hess
lie and so on and then moving on to
middle ranking nazis and then down to
ordinary supporters so
about a third of the way through doing
it and i hope it will appear in 2023.
okay excellent well thank you very much
uh mr evans we really appreciate it
uh again uh check out his new book
hitler conspiracies
um again uh if you have any interest in
the second world war you'll find it an
illuminating resource
uh and if you're interested in
contemporary politics uh which is what
really surprised me about it
you'll probably learn something as well
um so i hope you have a fantastic day
and again thank you so much for coming
on to our channel
okay thank you very much indeed for
inviting me thank you very much bye-bye
thank you bye professor here we go
[Music]